i'm hopeful
that the things between us
finally can get in good place
we can working on our problems and in
our communication
to be in better relationships
sit wherever you'd like
yours good
welcome it's so great for you both to be
here i'm really interested in what
brings you to couples therapy
well um
we've been really
trying to figure out some of our issues
you know we're engaged it's called off
we're not technically together as a
couple right now
it's hard because i do care and i know
he cares it's just i need
more consistency from him
i feel like
you know the way he communicates
not great at all and
i think he's afraid to open up and be
vulnerable and really tell me what he's
truly feeling so it's it's like it's
just hearts i want to be able to trust
him
sometimes i feel her trust problems
which is coming from past relationships
you know she's being hurt being
manipulative being lied she's being
cheated
i try never to give a reason to don't
trust me so nothing that you do to
really bring it on
um i don't know maybe i do i let the
past go i'm not trying to bring the past
up i'm trying to avoid past patterns i
want to break patterns i don't want to
be the same darcy i was in the past to
allow those things to happen again
the things that you've done
like you can't make excuses for that
i've had trust issues with my past
relationships but regardless
i have a hard time trusting georgie
because he's closed off
he doesn't take any accountability he
lies
so i need him to come clean and be
vulnerable and more open
i just want him to know that he can be
vulnerable with me and open up is that
part of what you want to do here
of course but i mean i'm here to
to focus on our relationship to make it
work
[Music]
you